وهي الان يتم حملها من سطح البحر الى هذه
المنطقه اليابسه او كما نسميها هي سفينه
مخصصه من اجل دراغون ما هي هذه المرحله
الان يتم تم استلام السفينه من سطح البحر
وسيتم نقلها باذن الله الى اليابسه سيتم
فتح الكبسوله والتاكد من سلامه رواد
الفضاء داخل الكبسوله ثم نقلهم والى
الخارج واحد اثار الحراره الشديده التي
كانت تواجه هذه المركبه واضح عليها
الاحتراق يعني نعم بفعل الايونات
والبلازما الموجوده في الغلاف الجوي يمكن
شاهدنا الشعله ويعني الشعله من اللهب
تخترق الغلاف الجوي وهي بفعل
المجال الايوني ولا البلازما الموجوده في
الغلاف الجوي يعني هل هذه المركبه يعني
وهي كبسوله صغيره مثل دمعه العين كما
نسميه يعني نتكلم عن اربع امتار في متر
ونصف او مترين تقريبا يعني هل قادره على
تحمل الحراره تصل الى 2000 درجه مئويه
السرعه 28 الف كيلو متر في الساعه الاشخاص
الذي بداخلها ما هو وضعهم يعني في هذه
اللحظات يعني تكلمت 12 دقيقه جزء من
الثانيه قد يعني يكون فيها تواجههم مشاكل
المركبه مصممه مصممه لهذه الرحله ويعني
يعني نتيجه تراكم ولا الخبرات والتقنيات
في السابق يعني تم تصميمها وانتاجها لتكون
قادره على تحمل هذه الرحله بكل ظروفها
ايضا الرواد الفضاء داخل الكبسوله يرتدون
البدلات
المزوده بالضغط المناسب وبالاكسجين
المناسب ايضا تم تدريبهم على ظروف التغير
في الجاذبيه وهذا جزء من البرنامج
التدريبي
الرواد والحمد لله يعني جميع الظروف جاءت
كما هو مخطط مهندس ماجد سوف يعني اطرح
عليك السؤال ايضا من خلال نقاشاتكم مع في
الفتره الماضيه قبل بدء هذا المشروع يعني
مع وكالات للفضاء سواء ناسا او غيرها
وكذلك هناك في اليابان كان هناك ايضا
زيارات قمتم بها وكان ايضا هناك استشارات
يعني ابرز ما
اللحظات الخطر التي قد تواجه هذه المركبه
او الحالات قد تكون مفاجئه بالنسبه لهذه
المركبه اين تكمل يمكن اثناء مرحله
الاطلاق يمكن اثناء انطلاق الصاروخ هذه
تعتبر مرحله حرجه ايضا مرحله الدخول الى
الغلاف الجوي هي المنطقه او المرحله
الاكثر الاكثر حرجا
يعني كما راينا يعني الحمد لله يعني تمت
تجاوزت المركبه جميع هذه الظروف وهذا
نتيجه يعني يعطينا مؤشر على زياده
الاعتماديه التي نراها الان في تقنيات
الفضائيه ويعني وجود هذه الكبسوله التي
مرت بالعديد مراحل التطوير والتجارب
والاختبارات وقامت بعدد من الرحلات
الفعليه لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات